this is a production of Cornell
University it's my pleasure to welcome
all to this afternoon to our seminar
with Leah Penniman I wanted to thank you
all for taking the time to join us and
putting aside your other duties and
responsibilities and worries for a
moment and to sit together in a
conversation and a contemplation of what
diversity looks like in agriculture what
it is what it could look like and how we
can contribute to that so I want to
first start by thanking our sponsors for
today we had several organizations that
helped contribute to hosting this event
I first want to highlight are the
minorities and agriculture natural
resources and related Sciences this is a
student group on campus and I'm so
excited to see them revived and here and
present again and so we'll be hearing a
little bit more from them in a while the
Cornell small farms program is extremely
proud to be hosting this the Center for
conservation Social Sciences the
Community Food Systems minor and the
school of integrated plan science so
thanks to all the sponsors that help
make us this happen so just a little
process after we hear from Leah we're
gonna have a panel discussion that's
facilitated by one of the manor students
Marquand Jones and we'll have Scott
Peters and Shona Allred and Raphael
Ponte and I join Mia in that panel
conversation and so we hope at that
point we can reflect some more on the
seminar and steps and thoughts for
moving forward so I ask you right now to
please silence your cellphone's turn
them off if you could if you could give
that up it would be wonderful take a
deep breath and just exhale come into
this room and set aside your worries
your duties and reach inside to that
part of yourself that really represents
your best self it's from this place that
I ask you to look around you can
with the wealth of experience the
diversity of experience and in the
wisdom that's in this room and think
about how it's this connection to each
other into the land into our histories
and our stories and this is at the core
of what Leah Penniman shares with us and
brings forth in her work I'd like to
read a couple of passages from her book
that have really resonated with me just
to sort of set the stage for this
afternoon and for those of you who would
like to purchase a copy
Leah's brought some copies with her and
they're in the back and so you can
actually purchase one one of the books
and I have some you can take a look
later a hundred years of enslavement
have devastated our sacred connection to
the land and overshadowed thousands of
years of our noble autonomous farming
history many of us have confused the
terror of our ancestors experienced on
the land with the land herself naming
her the oppressor and running toward
paved streets without looking back we do
not stoop Sweatt harvest or even get
dirty because we imagine that would
revert us to bondage and yet we are
keenly aware that something is missing
that a gap exists where there once was a
connection
another quote that I found really
resonant and moving is this one and I
have edited a little just to provide
context learning about George Washington
Carver Fannie Lou hammer Booker T Watley
and the new communities of Georgia I
realized that during all those years of
seeing images of only white people as
stewards of the land only white people
as organic farmers and only white people
in conversations about sustainability
the only consistent story I'd been told
about black people and the land was
about slavery and sharecropping about
coercion brutality misery and sorrow and
yet there's an entire history blooming
into our present in which black people's
expertise and love of the land and one
another was evident I found my purpose
in the land I personally really resonate
with this story because as a child as a
brown girl an immigrant and an outsider
it was in connecting intending a garden
that I found purpose and meaning that
physical and spiritual connection
offered to me was freely given by soil
and sunlight and in the plants that I
was growing but it engendered a type of
personal agency and self efficacy that I
couldn't get in a classroom I feel that
um that quote honoring and sort of
elevating the roles of many historical
black scientists is largely missing on
this quad it's largely missing in the
way that we think and talk about
agriculture in history and it's kin and
it's invisible and it's invisible in the
coursework and our collaborators in the
field so what is it that we can do how
can we think and propel our own work
forward especially by imagining how
bringing different perspectives into the
room will really help all of us grow
so in writing farming while black leah
has created a very approachable and
engaging guide for reconnecting with our
roots the land and each other she
invites black and Latina 'qs people to
reconnect to the land to heal wounds
past and present and to understand the
power of good hard work and to uplift
spiritual connections to ancestral
wisdom and other ways of knowing she's
outlined a path into farming
that's an antidote to the painful
associations of Agriculture with slavery
oppression and land loss and
discrimination
and it provides many many different ways
for black Latinas and all of us to think
together about how we can help each
other reclaim these places of dignity
and grow and activate our roles in the
food system while the book is entitled
farming while black I really invite I
feel that invites any reader to really
consider the ways we connect to nature
in the land and that power of that
connection to the land is and always
will be transformative
so Leah and her ever-growing family and
that operates Soulfire farm in Grafton
New York have been added since 2011 she
co-founded soulful farm with the mission
to end racism in the food system and to
reclaim our ancestral connection to the
land Lee as part of a team that
facilitates a powerful food sovereignty
program including farmer training for
black and brown people subsidized food
distribution program for people loving
living under food apartheid and regional
organizing towards equity in the food
system so with that I want to welcome
Leah and thank you so much for joining
us thanks everyone for having me do you
all know what FOMO is well that's what
I'm feeling because I've been farming
for 22 years and I've never taken a
single agricultural class and you all
get to immerse yourself in this amazing
environment of just wisdom and research
and knowledge so I'm wishing right now
that I could relive my college years and
be hanging out with you all but I do
have that real-life experience I've been
farming since I was a teenager and it's
really a blessing to be amongst all of
you because farmers are my people
they're the only ones who really get it
so we're gonna go on a little journey
and talk about black agrarianism and how
to heal a food system but for anyone who
is identifies as african-american or
who's been close to folks who are black
you know that we don't start any type of
event without a certain acknowledgement
first what is that you got it we always
be pour libation we give a shout out to
the ancestors because none of us got
here by ourselves right none of us
arrived here without the support and
legacy of generations and so we always
acknowledge ancestors before we speak
and I want to call into the room one
particular ancestor of mine her name is
Susie Boyd she's my grandma's grandma's
grandma
and she lived in the 1700s in what is
now Ghana West Africa and like so many
people are experienced in that time the
community was being ravaged as being
kidnapped people were being kidnapped
and transported in the transatlantic
slave trade to the Turtle Island to do
forced labor of course there were no
report back so people don't know exactly
why folks were being rounded up but
there was a lot of fear my family fled
to crow bone Mountain which is a
fortified mountain in the hills west of
Lake Volta and Ghana but still folks
were getting stolen in the night and and
so on so what the women in the community
decided to do facing this uncertain
future was to gather up their millet
their sorghum cow pee black rice egusi
melon sesame all these seeds that they
had been saving for generations and they
hid them in the parts of their braids
and their children's braids because they
believed against odds of in a future of
tilling and reaping on soil and they
believed that they would have
descendants who needed to inherit that
seed they had foresight they didn't give
up on us and in turn we are not to give
up on the future generations who need us
so I invite you so all so I'm calling in
Susy Boyd I invite you to think of an
ancestor who had foresight for you and
at the count of three we are going to
say their names really loud all at the
same time one two three ashay so another
thinks that we always give before we get
too far is a lands acknowledgments and
I'm going to acknowledge the
stockbridge-munsee Mohican people
because that's where my farms at and
while I do have indigenous heritage as a
tight you know person I am NOT Mohican
so I am enjoying some settler privilege
and it's not enough to name it it it
really demands solidarity and work
towards remate reiation so we've been
collaborating with the Mohican folks I
was out at the reservation in Wisconsin
last weekends to collaborate with them
on how to get some lands back how to get
some seeds back and really show up for
them so I want to know who you all need
to acknowledge whose land are we on
can anyone say a little bit about the
Cayuga nation people nations are the
comparison it doesn't have so we got to
work on that right very good thank you
thank you
and the third shout out that we give the
third thanks is to our team because we
have this little weird individualism
disease sometimes in the West where we
think like the civil rights movement
equals dr. Martin Luther King jr. but of
course it doesn't right there's always a
team there's always a squad there's
always a crew and in the case of
Soulfire Firm which I'll tell you a
little bit about in a moment you know
this is our team plus a few so I just
want to bring into the room Imani and
Larissa and Demarest and latisha
and also all the people who are feeding
your chickens and nursing your babies
and paying your taxes and doing whatever
else needs to be done so you can be here
because we're always part of a team and
that's the thanks i want to give and now
i'm gonna tell some stories anyone
haitian in the room okay so how do we
start our stories I say Creek and you
will say crack so Creek Creek good thank
you I'm gonna tell you a little bit
about our farm first before we get into
some history just so you know why it is
that even I'm the one talking to y'all
about this um so I've been farming like
I mentioned since I was 16 years old
back in 96 I got a job at the food
project outside of Boston Mass and I was
one of those young people that they
saved you know from myself farming
really saved my life and from there I
just kept trying to get jobs in the
summertime worked at many hands organic
farm I worked at farm school I work for
the community gardens and Worcester Mass
and eventually decided to start my own
farm after getting years and years of
experience and what catalyzed that was
this one moment when my husband Jonah
and I were living in the south end of
Albany which is a food apartheid
neighborhood meaning that no matter how
hard you try
you're not gonna be able to get fresh
food no grocery stores no farmers
markets no available community garden
plots no public transportation I have a
master's degree I know how to farm and I
know how to get what I want I could not
get fresh food for my newborn and my
two-year-old so what I ended up doing
was joining a farm share CSA that had a
drop-off 2.2 miles up a hill so I would
put one baby in the stroller one of the
backpack go up there and pile the heavy
fall vegetables onto the children you
know and then roll back down the hill so
that would that was the only way to get
fresh food and when our neighbors found
out that we knew how to farm they were
like so you all know how to grow food
and you're not doing it for us
let's get going so Soulfire was really
born out of a community clamor for a
farm for the people we got some really
crappy lands really cheap up in the
hills of Grafton New York all the
farmers down in the valley we're like
you cannot grow vegetables on that land
it's like class 13 whatever really bad
but these are vegetables they're
beautiful because we used all Afro
indigenous methods to heal the soil
which we'll get into what those are and
what's different about our distribution
system is that we boxed up all these
vegetables right every Wednesday from
June to November we put them in this
creepy white van that's less creepy
because of the sticker slightly and the
cute teenager who was the baby big and
we do it we do doorstep delivery so we
deliver in neighborhoods where there are
not supermarkets or farmers markets or
fresh food and people pay what they can
afford on a sliding scale so folks who
have more money pay more folks about
less money pay less kind of even though
our farm does make money so that's
that's very important and very
challenging for a small scale vegetable
operation but we have 80 acres and we
intensively cultivate about two and a
half and vegetables and two and a half
and pasture-raised poultry and orchard
so that that's a situation we have a
hundred CSA members about 350
individuals so out of that out of having
a farm which is enough work we started
getting a lot of calls from people we
got calls from parents who said it's
nice to get your food however my child
is being harassed by the police all
summer because they have nothing to do
and there
picked up for loitering or petty crimes
like you need to do something for the
black and brown use an open e helped us
right we started getting calls for
people from people saying I would love
to be a farmer but I can't find a
culturally respectful place to work I
can't find a place where I don't
experience microaggressions I'm getting
rejected from incubators I can't afford
Aguilar s'ti all of this can you train
me how to farm so we realized we need an
educational component so we started a
lot of things we have a youth program we
have a alternative to incarceration
program camp training programs for black
and brown farmers like basically
thousands of people are just rolling
through the farm learning various things
anything from a one-day workshop to a
one-year apprenticeship and in addition
to teaching folks fun things like cation
exchange capacity we also specialize in
looking exceptionally fly while hanging
onions and so we did this for a few
years right the education part and then
we get a challenge from an elder in our
community his name is Baba Curtis
Mohammed he's a civil rights veteran and
former Black Panther experienced a lot
of physical violence against his family
in the 60s and eventually moved to
Brazil to escape kind of an nuts ness of
the United States so he came up to visit
our farm for dinner one time and he was
like oh this is cute you know y'all
grown vegetables and chickens and this
young people that's really nice do you
know what real farmers dude he's like
real farmers are the backbone of the
civil rights movement you know real
farmers in the 1960s provided all the
housing the food they leveraged their
land as collateral for bail money to get
folks out of jail the activists like the
black farmers because they owned their
own land they couldn't be fired from
their job so they could register to vote
during the end of lease ACP join a
picket line with comparatively less
threat than the sharecroppers and you
know you go in the south and you peer
into the windows of these houses with
black farmers back in the late 60s and
it would look like Bible study but it
wasn't Bible study because in the
Bible's were voter registration
pamphlets they were organizing meetings
right and if folks caught win
night rider's were coming to try to
string up the activists the farmers
would go cut down trees to block the
road so that people had time to escape
he's like literally there would be no
civil rights movement without land
owning black farmers it would not have
happened it's not like you could get a
hotel Convention Center for the
n-double-a-cp
in Georgia it didn't happen right so he
was like you need to make sure that
you're providing this resource for the
movement and so that's when sort of the
third and four now final branch of what
we do at Soulfire came about is really
making sure that our land was available
for new york state prisoner justice
coalition cam you know all these
organizations that are doing organizing
work as well as our own anti-racist
organizing so this is one such meeting
some of the projects we do we have a
reparations map which matches donors to
black farmers to transfer anything from
a hug to a tractor we have land trust
that we're forming in the Northeast and
we'll do be doing a workshop about that
tomorrow but it's a collaboration
between black indigenous and Latin X
farmers to try to do land reparations so
a lot of projects that are more on the
organizing side of things we weighed in
on the farm bill weighing in on the new
greed deal that type of stuff and then
we have international comrades in four
places outside of our borders so Puerto
Rico Haiti Ghana and Mexico we have
sibling farms and every year we provide
volunteer support funds to support
things like this is a peanut growers
collective there's a mango growers
collective in Haiti that we help them
out with whatever they need so that is a
little bit about soulfire and you can
see why I'm so fired up and passionate
about the work but it took a long time
to get there like I almost quit farming
when I was around 18 because I would go
to every single farming conference I
would dutifully read every single book
that Chelsey green publishing put out
and I did not see one person of color
presents as an expert one person write a
book and I actually got challenged from
people in my community like why are you
focusing on trees in soil like you
should be focusing on gun violence and
housing and education like real issues
you're a trader you know you're a trader
to us and that's pretty compelling and
so I almost quit farming and
cailli the earth and the ancestors were
trying to call me back in and I had one
person do you all know Karen Washington
here in Washington is a black farmer at
rising root farm she also started the
black urban growers Network she met me
as a teenager and she was like don't
give up like one day we will have a
conference one day we will have books
like it's gonna happen you know and she
was right
she was really right so farming while
black is about the other side of black
agrarian history not just the slavery
side of it and it is a love letter to
that teenage self I needed to know that
she belongs
so hopefully is a love letter to the
next generation this is a painting that
my sister made of the moment of braiding
the seeds into the hair anyone um get
their hair braided by their parents er
Aziz okay so what happens while you're
getting the braids in yanking and
hitting but what else happens if your
tender head it takes a long time right
so while you're doing the braids you're
telling stories you're sharing culture
sharing information and so my belief is
that while our ancestors were in West
Africa hiding those seeds in their hair
they were also getting a lot of
information about the right way to farm
to be in relationship with the earth and
to be in relationship with community and
the project of colonization has been to
try to make us forget and the project of
our liberation is remembrance so I will
tell you what was getting braided into
our hair but first I want to see what
you already know okay so I'm curious
what black agrarian practices you
currently use on your farm or garden or
that you're studying and I'll give you
some clues some themes right do you know
any black soil testing practices maybe
black crop selections livestock
practices tools preservation methods
land ownership marketing any strategies
that have come out of black history that
inform your farming so I'm gonna give
you two minutes to talk to the person
next to you don't be scared you don't so
marry them just two minutes
and then I'll ask for a couple folks to
just share out and then I'll give you
the answer so it's no stress no test or
anything okay two minutes
when I say free the people you say free
the land free the people
when I say free the people you say free
the land free the people by any means
necessary
alright who's brave founding to manage
moisture and temperature
I don't know is a financier - yeah sorry
comrade saying it hurts not to know
because our land was taken in history
was taking one more doctor George
Washington Carver and green manure yeah
we'll definitely get to that so you all
know some things but not all the things
so I can't dismiss the class so here we
go let's start with just crops you know
there's many crops that come from the
continent itself and then there's a lot
of crops where varieties were refined by
enslaved Africans so things like green
glazed collards and the Moyamensing
tomato
you know tomatoes and collards do not
come from Africa but a lot of the
varieties that have been popularized
were grown by enslaved Africans and and
plant bred by enslaved Africans but
these crops here actually come from the
continent so okra coffee : uh black rice
many many types of melon eggplants
cotton sesame gourds and so on so many
of us do grow those crops
so these soils I love this picture
because I had the foresight to save some
soil from when we first got to our lands
in my left hand is 2006 in my right hand
is 2018 everyone said we couldn't grow
there
it was completely deforested it was
eroded it was over grazed the rocks were
showing through
you know you get through this much
topsoil and then you would hit this hard
pan clay which is what you can see there
and the organic matter was around to two
and a half percent it's now twelve and
why that's so significant is because
when Europeans first got to the United
States on average the soils and the
Great Plains were around eight to ten
percent organic matter and you all know
organic matters like the life carbon is
the life of the soil within one
generation twenty-eight years the
average soil organic matter and the
Great Plains was between three and four
percent so more than half was tilled
right out of the soil and pushed up into
the atmosphere this is before the
Industrial Revolution so most of the
times when we look at atmospheric co2
graphs we start with that but the first
spike was actually the tilling of the
Great Plains and our farm manager Louisa
Jacobson says that her life's work is
calling carbon back to the soil which I
love so every percent organic matter
increase is her manifesting her destiny
work um I also love this picture because
almost everything you need to know about
soil you can learn through your five
senses so the Yoruba people in Nigeria
know how to test soil with their tongues
can tell pH down so the difference
between 6.5 and 6.0 by how sweet or sour
the soil is measure pH with our tongue
I've tried it I haven't trained my
tongue I can like imagine that I can
taste the difference but now really does
anyone done texture by feel that also
comes out of West Africa determining the
particle size of the mineral portion of
soil how greedy have smooth how long the
ribbon is in fact Western scientists
have you know gone to Africa is like oh
my goodness their soil classic
Asians are as complex as ours how could
it be right but a lot of the things that
we know about soil are rooted in afro
indigenous practice
does anyone manage their soil to
encourage earthworms or do vermicompost
they're pretty great right
so Cleopatra started that 59 BCE in
Egypt
Cleopatra recognized that earthworms
were the key to the fertility of the
Nile River Delta and so she made it
illegal to harm an earthworm on pain of
death he actually would be put to death
if you heard an earthworm which is
terrifying cuz it's very easy to hurt
one and she had a whole cadre of priests
whose full-time work was dedicated to
the study of the habits of earthworms
and how to increase them in 1949 USDA
researchers went over ended soil cores
and we're like oh my goodness there's 10
to 40 times any one of worm castings
here as there are in our soils and it
was because of basically Cleopatra sheep
vermicompost of her entire empire to
make sure that there would be the
fertility that we have so we can thank
her for why these little children and
Canada are happy with the red worms
there these women are in Ghana West
Africa and something that's so profound
about their soil management is that you
can do soil cores they're down seven
hundred years and the core looks like
rings of a tree because every generation
is responsible for adding to the depth
of the dark earth and dark earth is a
combination of bone char kitchen scraps
waste from the fields you know ash from
the fire all combined and composted in a
certain way and every person every
generation needs to lay down a certain
depth to that dark earth so the soil
gets deeper and better each year so you
can soil core it and you can measure the
age of the community by the rings of the
earth so we can thank women in Ghana for
our understanding of compost
doesn't look very good right what is
this slash and burn rate that's exactly
how I was tie it was like the enemy of
the earth like slash and burn
agriculture what I didn't know is that
sweat in agriculture which is the more
respectful name for slash and burn is
actually an ancient and super
sustainable farming technology the way
it was originally conceived it's a 20 to
30 year crop rotation with the forest as
the cover crop and so you farm a certain
area for a year or two right and then as
the soil becomes depleted moved to a new
area such that the entire rotation takes
a generation to get back to that
original plot in the meantime a forestry
grows and when as we know forests do a
great job of pulling minerals out from
deep in the earth putting down leaf
litter you know as compost and
completely regenerating the carbon
stores in the soil so the by the time
you get back it actually does make sense
to go ahead and burn and release those
nutrients and make them available
the challenge is colonialism when you
steal people's land and push them into a
tiny little space those rotations that
used to take a generation now take just
a couple of years not sustainable that's
how I got the name slash and burn and
how indigenous people got other dand
demonized as enemies of the earth when
in fact it was colonization that was
forcing folks to use the land in that
way so every time I do crop rotation
I think indigenous folks in Africa as
well as Southeast Asia and Turtle Island
for the genius that is swidden
agriculture so we thank folks for a crop
rotation anyone ends up my culture okay
good
be unpopular with three people cuz I
this is the part that people don't like
so permaculture doesn't really exist
unfortunately permaculture is a process
of appropriating indigenous technologies
from all around the world and putting
them under a new heading and then
commercializing it not for the benefit
of indigenous people which is a real
bummer one of the popular well-known
techniques of permaculture is
agroforestry these idea that you can you
know have woody perennials and then
around them maybe some aromatic herbs
that repel pests and then around that
maybe your grazing your chickens and
your annuals and your very you know that
whole system that is relatively
self-sustaining in Nigeria alone there's
over 30 agroforestry systems that have
been documented one of them made it over
to Haiti it's called the Jaden la ku
then local just means home garden but
like any agroforestry system you have
many multiple layers of plants you have
perennials and annuals you have herbs
and fruits Moringa and Limon and this
here is a nursery that we helped to
build in Vionnet in Haiti that provides
families with the plants for their
agroforestry system there's none like
who which everybody has so we shout out
Afro indigenous farmers for what we call
permaculture as well and here's us
trying to build Asheton la ku
unfortunately I could not get Moringa or
mangoes or lemons or any of that to grow
so we just have apples and plums and
things like that which are also somewhat
exciting but not as exciting but this
points out another technology which is
the terrace the terrace ah which arose
simultaneously in Mesoamerica as well as
Eastern Africa in Kenya is called fun
Yazoo Vanya zu means throw it upwards in
Kiswahili any idea I love that name in
India why call a terrace throw it
upwards
made a terrorist before what do you have
to do that's probably saves labor but on
our farm we did have to throw it upwards
because we got this land that was very
eroded so literally at the bottom of the
slope there would be a stone wall and
the soil was all the way up level to the
stone wall above the stone wall and then
below you'd have like four or five feet
of wall so you can see how much soil had
just washed down the hill visually so we
quite literally dug it up you know
tractor buckets and whatever and threw
it up to build our terraces so I imagine
that's why they call it that but this
technology of course controls erosion it
makes lands that are otherwise not
manageable for agriculture manageable
for agriculture and tools almost all of
our agricultural tools came from Africa
originally they've been modified of
course my favorite one is the hoe the
hoe is invented in sub-saharan Africa
it's the most universal the most widely
used farming tool you can use it in wet
land and dry land up land and down you
can use it for primary tillage and
harvesting and cultivation I don't
particularly like these kind of hoes I
like those like 20-pound honkin big hose
that you can pretty much only get in
West Africa or Haiti so anytime I go I
stuff my luggage with a lot of sharp
metal and then negotiate with the air
people but I recommend those so we get
things for our tools we give thanks for
irrigation you know the oldest
irrigation that we know of again East
Africa it's the basin system which is
essentially digging a series of canals
and ditches and and things to flood
irrigate and that's still used in many
places around the world it works well
especially in rice paddies the next
oldest irrigation system is called the
folk gara and that was created a couple
thousand years ago in the Sahel desert
in Africa and it is a people actually
dug and dug through bedrock to get down
to aquifers and then used a series of
air wells
like pump this water over to their date
fields and these are still in use like
in Algeria these thousands of year old
irrigation systems are still in use so
we give thanks to black farmers for
helping us realize that we could grow
food in the desert and giving us the
technology to do it
rotational grazing comes out of the
black community as well the whole idea
right that you have your livestock first
and they eat a bunch of pests and they
go ahead and deposit their manure and
fertilizer move to a new spot and then
you can put your your horticultural
crops in after that to enjoy and so on
and rotate it around and gallinaceous
birds in particular are rooted in Africa
the very very oldest domesticated
livestock that we have record of is the
guinea hen which is a relative of the
chicken so the guinea guinea fowl goes
back as far as any records go that
people have been connected to the guinea
hen but black folks have a neat
relationship with the chicken to which
comes out of a problematic history which
is during the time of enslavement black
people were not allowed to own any
bigger livestock so chickens were not in
the law but things like goats pigs cows
that black people are not allowed to own
them see if you go back to Jefferson's
records like President Jefferson he
would buy all of his chicken from
enslaved Africans because I was the only
thing they were allowed to raise on
their own but because of that a lot of
the varieties we have of chickens and
the methods we have a raising chickens
come out of enslaved Africans
methodology so shout out to black
farmers for the chicken any guess
old that tomato is this guy's in Burundi
holding a tomato that he just pulled out
of a box of ash how old do you think it
is a few months it's six months old and
like super fresh good still eat the
tomato because preserving an ash and dry
soil is a technology for food
preservation that's been perfected in
Burundi and other parts of Africa as
well as fermentation smoking drying and
a lot of the ways that we hold on to our
food
you mentioned bounding raised beds
raised beds are amazing I'll tell you a
quick story about him because you know
all the ways that we already know
they're amazing like the soil warms up
earlier and water management all that
stuff in 2013 it was was a hurricane
sandy in 2013 which hurricane was that I
lost track I think it was sandy and like
washed away like a bunch of New York
City and it washed away a bunch of farms
in school Harry Valley so in the middle
of the night during that hurricane my
husband and I woke up simultaneously
because it sounded like a Mack truck was
coming towards our house and we looked
outside and where there was once forest
there was now this river just rushing
down towards us and headed straight for
our Allium fields like headed for our
garlic and our onions and all of that
was gonna wash it all away so we woke up
our children put shovels in their hand
and made them dig trenches with us
to divert the river like around the
Allium garlic is a must
went back to sleep woke up in the
morning and my little son was so cute he
was about this big at the time and he
was afraid he would drown in the like
you know this much water so he has all
the pictures of he has a lifejacket on
while going up what was amazing is we
lost almost nothing and we lost almost
nothing because everything on our farm
is in permanent raised beds and so all
the water got slowed down and
channelized and absorbed and it made us
really grateful thinking about how these
technologies are
help prevent climate change but also
contributes to climate resiliency in the
face of these extreme weather events and
as a bonus does anyone know what plant
is on top of this farmers mounds I
actually learned this from an audience
member I didn't know it's neem yea which
kills nematodes which is super smart
things like the work party comes out of
dope way in the Dahomey region or combee
in Haiti the idea that we can all get
together and help each other out that's
a really important technology to our
social technologies credit unions called
sousou's originally where we all put in
a little bit of money and we can take
loans out from each other to capitalize
our farms so that if you need to buy a
cow like we're all there for you and we
help you buy that cow also comes out of
a community of black caribbean farmers
and our spiritual technologies so I'll
tell you another quick story
um I studied farming in Ghana amongst
other places and there's a group of
older black women there who call
themselves the Queen Mother's well
they're elected queen mothers and I call
themselves and they're in charge of the
morality of the community they're in
charge of the farms they're in charge of
taking care of the orphans they're
really incredible and when I was there
they had a fun game to play where they
would call me in and ask me about life
in the United States on a daily basis
new question every day so one day they'd
be like immediately come come come out
is it true that in the United States the
woman will be stirring the soup pot and
the man will be adding salts yeah this
gender roles are different right so they
thought that was so funny like just so
funny that we would be collaborating I'm
making soup like who's doing the other
stuff so then the next day they call me
and like immediately is it true that a
United States the farmer will put a seed
in the ground and they will pour no
libation they won't sing they won't
dance they won't even say thank you to
the earth and then they expect a harvest
think is that really true
and of course it's it's very true
so they said that's why you're all sick
that's why you sick you're sick because
you think the earth is a material thing
that you can just take and take and take
and take and you don't realize the earth
is in a Risha right the earth is a
living being she's your mother and she
demands reciprocity and consents so
don't tell don't come back to Ghana and
tell me that you're doing that like I
want to I want you to be giving libation
giving honor so this is us kind of
looking very silly but we're trying to
make sure that we honor the spiritual
ecology also of farming first extension
agency Tuskegee University black college
in Alabama Booker T Washington was
realizing that a lot of farmers could
not get to the University so the
university needs to get to the farmers
originally with a carts and a mule in
the 1800's went out and actually read I
just finished reading this primary
source it's fascinating it's called the
moveable school goes to the Negro farmer
it's this like turn of the century old
leather-bound very very interesting but
about this and their method was like an
extreme makeover reality show so they
would find the crappiest farm with the
sickest animals the like ramshackled
house they would get the whole community
to come over and they would like nurse
the livestock back to how they'd fix the
fences they'd prune the trees they would
do erosion control they put cover crops
in and then that became the
demonstration site for the community
super interesting I read the grant
report where they were upgraded from a
mule and a car to this car and like how
they begged for money and how important
it was so shout out to Tuskegee
University for extension we're pretty
into that shout out to Booker T Watley
also a professor at Tuskegee he came up
with the CSA and pick-your-own
so that whole movement of like direct
farmer to consumer that was not a thing
and so Watley at the time people were
doing all middlemen they were doing
commodity crops they were doing
monoculture and he was noticing that
folks were just not making any money
he's like you know I have this idea they
thought he was totally nuts I have this
idea like city folks miss the country no
we have this big urbanization thing need
to make them feel like they belong so
we're gonna have
membership to farms and newsletters so
that they feel really connected and
you're gonna have farm tours and visits
a lot of things we take for granted as
ways that small farmers can make it came
out of a black University under Watley
this is his book making $100,000 on 25
acres that was a lot of money then
George Washington Carver
famous for the peanut why was he into
peanuts what family of plants are they
legumes are magical right legumes are
like hay right so Bale bacteria come
over here I have a nice little home for
you and my route I'm a feed you sugar
it's gonna have just the right balance
of different gases that you need and all
you have to do is turn atmospheric
nitrogen into organic nitrogen and seed
me it's a perfect perfect synergy and
it's why organic AG is possible so same
thing people thought that George
Washington Carver was pretty nuts with
this obsession with the peanut and
telling farmers that they should take
land out of production and put it in
leguminous cover crops that was not a
popular idea so what he had to do to
convince people was to quote the bible
if you look at his speeches he would be
talking to a room like this and be
quoting proverbs and stuff and just be
like you know like an injustice against
the smallest of us is an injustice
against everything so if you disrespect
the soil life you disrespect God so he
was like telling farmers that in the
fall they shouldn't just rest after the
harvest they should go to the swamps and
gather up muck and make compost piles
and leaves and gather their livestock
manure and plant their cover crops so he
was talking about regenerative soil
systems a whole generation before the
Rodale Institute he was the first
agricultural professor to be teaching
organic farming in the United States
indigenous technologies yes but as far
as institutionalizing that knowledge and
passing it on that was the beginning so
shout out for organic agriculture itself
the land trust came out of the black
community this is the first Community
Land Trust in Albany Georgia 6000 acres
run by 500 families they were bombs and
shot at and their animals were killed
for that audacity has black people to
own land together but they started the
land trust movement food hubs we thanked
the Barkers and the black churches in
the southeast for starting the first
food hubs they used to just be in the
shed in the back of the church where all
the farmers would bring their produce
and aggregate it and sell it so
congregants and if they had too much
they'd rent a truck and take it up to
Chicago or Pittsburgh along the
underground along the great migration
lines railroad lines and then sell it
out of the churches there so that was
the beginning of aggregation and
distribution of perishables by farmers
and here they are winning an award at
last year's black farmers conference for
their role in the food hub movement we
think Africa for helping us clean up
urban soils so I'll tell you one more
quick story I'm mostly a rural farmer
but I spent a bunch of time doing urban
farming too and this is Western
Massachusetts where my husband and I who
was then just my friend
we ran the community gardens for the
city and we started a youth farm called
youth grow still going it's really great
you should check it out we had a tiny
little baby shortly thereafter and
brought her with us who doesn't the baby
helps weed you know she puts her little
bean seeds in the ground it's very cute
we take her to her one and a half year
old checkup and she has lead poisoning
there's no lead in our house she had
lead poisoning from contact with the
soil so being the activist mom that I am
I went around and tested the soil for
led all around the city because the city
had never bothered to do that the
Environmental Protection Agency's safe
limit is 400 parts per million
we found 11,000 parts per million in the
drip line in some playgrounds and
community gardens which is like super
fund level obscenely high so we started
youth co-op this is called the toxic
soil Buster's it's a youth owned
business these are actual hazmat suits
and the young people we got
check with the city to clean up
immobilize lead and to pay the youth to
do that work and our secret weapon is
this little flower from Africa called
the scented geranium or pale Argonian
which is a hyper accumulator so if you
have lead under about 1200 ppm s with a
year - of chelation and phytoremediation
you can get that lead level down and so
we would use this geranium to suck that
lead out of the soil and fix up our
garden areas so that's just a few
examples there's a lot more shout out to
black people for all things organic
farming but I just want to mention
briefly - that there are some societal
conditions that are preventing us from
flourishing and that's why I hope in the
panel we can get into talking a little
bit about how to dismantle those
boundaries so number one access to land
all land is stolen all the land that
black people managed to acquire by 1910
almost all of that is gone and there's a
whole history of why that is it has to
do with everything from overt racist
violence like killing people who owned
lands to government discrimination so
that's number one thing you got to have
land to be able to farm number two thing
is that nearly all of the labor that we
rely on in this country is labor that is
somehow exploited or coerced even
indirectly you know we create
international trade agreements that make
life in Mexico or the Caribbean so
onerous that folks go across a border to
a hostile land to do work for sub
minimum wage that you know Americans the
documents don't want to do so it started
with slavery but it's just morphed right
so we really have to address the dignity
that needs to be inherent in farm labor
to restore black agrarianism you don't
get any food to eat right if you're
black or brown in this country you are
way more likely to have diabetes heart
disease obesity poor eyesight ADHD
hunger itself again not cuz we don't
know how to make kale salad or like
wanna eat well but because of a whole
history of housing discrimination which
leads to ghettoization of people under
investment in neighborhoods structural
racism that prevents folks from
eating good food and also having the
purchasing power to buy the good food
from with from the black farmers in our
community so we need to address the
consumer side of things
the fourth thing is as you know
industrial AG is trashing the planet and
I won't go into that too much hopefully
we know about that
and we know how we know good message to
farm we know black and indigenous
regenerates of farm methods but those
are either ignored underfunded or at
best appropriated so that someone else
capitalizes on them
and finally there's a lot of trauma you
know there's no way that your people can
go through hundreds of years of
enslavement and sharecropping and
lynching and forced migration and not be
a little bit jittery around the lands
you know literally everybody like the
young folks who come to my farm at first
their first Association is slavery even
though it's black and brown people
running the farm they chose to come they
tease each other like oh you asleep
right that's that's our first
association and so the work within our
communities is to disentangle that
association like the land is why we
survived all that she was never the
enemy she was a scene of the crime but
she was never the criminal and so
there's a lot of healing that needs to
go on for us to be able to reclaim that
dignity
so the question I want to leave you all
with and we can talk about in the panel
and the QA is how can we show some more
respects right to the black agrarian
tradition and how can we carry on that
legacy
of the seeds that were braided into our
ancestors hair skip this I'm just gonna
close with a quote and then we'll have
light a few questions and then so this
quote is from Michael Twitty who's an
amazing black culinary historian
definitely check out his books if you
haven't yet but I love this it says I
need to hear the bumping of pesto's
making percussion with sunrise and
Twilight's I need the scratch of grading
tubers and the grinding of spices on
stone I need the sonic world of the
ancestors lullabies said while babies
are fed body songs as the land is smooth
for planting I need to understand the
sound of the wind and the rice and the
complexities of the yam mounds
intercropped to save space I need the
rustle of the oil palm fronds so I can
hear the generations speak so thank you
[Applause]
or into your program I mean being
small-scale we're a little blessed that
we can get away with all that kind of
stuff so we have a lot of small projects
so I know a den like ooh around our
apple trees we have about 20 or 30
different kinds of medicinal herbs and
we have one of the things I was meeting
with the Mohican folks about is a seed
remediation project we're gonna do with
them so they don't have as many growers
on the reservation as they would like so
we're going to grow out some of their
seed and like mail it to them to try to
increase like they have certain
varieties of bee balm that are really
secret to them and and other crops like
that so we we grow black crowds we also
grow like a lot of indigenous crops -
yeah and it's one thing that's so
wonderful when youth come the idea that
you can grow your own medicine I blow
their mind so I'm like oh you have
trouble sleeping at night like have some
lemon balm and chamomile and just pick
it and like just take a home and make
tea so if it has a powerful educational
thing to like you know to rely on CBS
for your life yeah I mean I think
learning first is really important and a
lot of folks the first thing they want
to do is like get land and start and I
think that can be a recipe for
disappointment
and so we have beginner training
programs up through more advanced and
then when people graduate we provide
ongoing mentorship so it's we could we
nicknamed it blacks tension like black
extension and so I often will go visit
people's farms and help them out and
also help them connect to the wider
resources but for a lot of people this
see
d of a caucus and an identity group when
they're getting started is really
important so that as they get ready to
kind of branch out and so maybe what
small farms has to offer what other
organizations have to offer I mean a
beautiful story I'm sure my research was
so tantalizing and fun I never thought
of myself as a writer but it was my
favorite thing to do besides pruning
trees um so it started with a hypothesis
that every single important thing in
sustainable agriculture was in some way
connected to black people and then
trying to find it so I would be like
raised beds what's the history and I had
there was an NYU professor named Juliet
Tarantino who was my research assistant
so I would say to her something like I
heard that Cleopatra was into worms can
you find out if that's true and give me
like an annotated bibliography of that
so she was very helpful cuz you can't
just write whatever you feel like
writing in a book you really have to
like find the papers but as a lot of
dense old like USDA papers and old
things that we uncovered it was really
fun maybe one more question and then or
zero invite my queen to mark went to
thank you guys so yeah I just want to
first introduce myself my name is Mark
Juan Jones I'm a junior here at Cornell
I study development sociology I'm a
Community Food Systems minor in an
inequality Studies minor I'm from
Chicago and I have a background in urban
farming so I was really delighted to be
here today so I guess all the panelists
could you introduce yourselves
[Music]
I'm Scott Peters I'm a professor in the
department of development sociology and
work in this newly established Community
Food Systems undergraduate minor that
Marquand is one of our members of
student so I teach the capstone course
in that curriculum good afternoon my
name is Shauna Allred I'm a professor in
the Department of Natural Resources and
the southeast asia program and do
research in the environmental justice
arena folks my name is raphael aponte
anybody called me Rafa I'm the
owner/operator of rocky acres community
farm
Tenneco farm just outside of town raised
goats chickens diversified vegetables
doing education programs and activism
and I'll just share anu.rangarajan
I'm the director of the Cornell small
farm program and do research on
sustainable vegetable production and one
to ten thousand acres I'm Leah alright
guys so first question you please share
how your work and research ins is
supporting diversity efforts of farmers
in the u.s. or your plans of doing this
[Music]
do you guys need the mic do I have to
this always strange house well I used to
be able to say that I was the only black
farmer in the county it's not a proud
title right but that's no longer true
there's a there's two more farmers that
have been added to the ranks this year
but previously I've been the only owner
opera operator of a form within Tompkins
County now this is the county that's
holding I was sitting in the land-grant
institution for the University for the
for the entire state of New York
yet I was the only farmer black farmer
that was an owner of the land that they
worked in Tompkins County so in that way
I'm helping the diversity efforts by
putting a number on the board and I
encourage you know more folks to join me
there are reasons I think that that you
kind of shine light on that that folks
aren't engaged or aren't able to get the
resources or capital to start these kind
of projects but it's coming along it's
coming along we need a lot more work
though I can just share a few efforts
within the small farm program and some
of the work that we're doing we're
really thinking deeply about how do we
strengthen our connections to urban
farmers and urban communities of
individuals who aspire to farm but don't
even have that in their imagination yet
and so we just got a new grant and we're
excited about it to work on urban
mushroom production and sort of
developing collaborative marketing
opportunities but then connecting those
farmers to farmers upstate New York to
start different kinds of conversations
conversations that are of shared
resource of shared ability shared
aspiration we also but just one example
but we think we're thinking a lot about
that as a program and some of the work
that I do also goes to South Africa I
work with black women farmers in South
Africa and that's been a real joy
because the connection between what they
aspire to and do and what I observe and
experience working with farmers here is
really similar I just have to say that
three people who are part of the
Northeast farmers of color are in the
mushroom class and they love it like I
get text updates so it's working like
urban farmers like oh and we went
upstate and now I got my bag and all I
think so thank you the second question
is as we have heard and Leah's book and
in her lecture the farming practices
that she uses our combination of
indigenous place-based knowledge most
likely oral traditions that have proven
to give higher yields and more
sustainability why do you think
researchers have not acknowledged this
and how can you see these couple
together is there a way to create an
interdisciplinary approach to solving
these issues so I think that's a really
important point and in Leah's book and
then also in her talk you know she
really started off by talking about our
importance of acknowledging the rich
knowledge and history that comes from
our ancestors and I think that that
often goes unnoticed and I think there
are researchers that are beginning to to
look at the indigenous knowledge of
communities and to really give you know
to privileged that that knowledge in the
same way that scientific knowledge is
often often privileged and so I think
some of that is changing I'll give a
shout-out to Gloria blaze here in the
first row she's a master student she's
actually doing research in in Haiti on
agroforestry practices with local
communities so she's going to be you
know contributing to the science of how
communities practice agroforestry but
also helping to spread the models of
these community-based approaches to
incorporating that kind of traditional
knowledge
so I'll say a few words about the
community food systems undergraduate
minor my colleague Rachel Besner Kerr is
here who is leading this as a faculty
member and teaches the kind of
foundation class and in the curriculum
the the minor came out of a five-year
initiative that was called food dignity
and that project was a partnership with
five different local food justice
projects one in Oakland California two
in Wyoming one in New York City and one
here in Ithaca and it came from a a
recognition that there was a lot
emerging and happening around the world
that people were in fact hard at work
and trying to build a just food system
and that institutions like Cornell
University didn't know very much about
what they were doing and needed to be in
a position of learning which is the
opposite of what we usually think about
a university we're supposed to be the
ones teaching but but there's a was a
recognition that there was a lot
happening and emerging that that
required us to be more in a position of
learning but also in a position of using
our power our privilege our position to
access resources that could be offered
to those leaders out in those
communities so food dignity and we
actually got five million dollars from
USDA for an action research project and
the Corbett recognized that the leaders
in the local food justice communities
were were producing knowledge and and
drawing on large legacies of knowledge
as your work is is helping us to learn
and know so the miner came out of that
whole experience and is now set up in a
way that we hope will will help continue
to offer ways for students to be
contributing through their labor and and
time and learning and for us to be
finding ways to continue to support the
researchers the knowledge creators the
producer
that are out there on the leading edge
of food justice work in our communities
and we have a long long long long long
way to go living up to the potential of
what an institution like this could do
but with students like Marquand coming
into this minor were really enthused
about the possibilities of doing justice
to where the knowledge is and the
struggles that people are having it and
local communities to to organize a just
food system I think we we have to come
to terms with with what industrial
agriculture is and how it's tied to
capitalism and it is ceaseless March
right and it's effective it works right
it is affected by producing capital
what's also effective at is
externalizing its harms right and that
harms most of the times ends up
impacting the most marginalized
communities so all the generative
projects that end up coming out and the
reclaim the reclamation of history ends
up being a response to the harms right
it pops up where the harms have been
done the most so I wouldn't have got
into agriculture this wasn't a call back
to the land for me you know out of you
know I wanted to get more birds you know
I wanted my the pitches were fine you
know I wanted I wanted my community to
eat you know I wanted to be able to have
healthy access to these things and and
looking and talking to my ancestor to my
parents about my ancestors they were
like don't get into this like we came
all the way from we don't want you to
get back in the agriculture don't do
that um and not at my biggest fans like
we're so glad you're able to work on
your own terms own the means of
production it doesn't come from a place
of exploitation so for me that works you
know but the the industrial agriculture
it doesn't have to deal with those
questions so I think it's up to us
suppose those two
and say which one works better right
under what circumstances I'll just share
a short story that we do a lot of work
supporting people getting into farming
and I think one of the biggest
challenges that we've observed over time
is you can teach people all of the you
can provide a sort of a recipe for how
to do things but the skill that's the
hardest lot to learn is how to read the
land and how to read the environment and
integrate to make decisions and that
kind of observation is something that if
you haven't had the chance to work
alongside with somebody takes a long
time to learn because what you're
integrating are all of your senses
you're integrating moving things you're
integrating the signals on the land you
learn to recognize certain plants as
representing certain changes on the land
those are hard to teach and so that's
where I think it's really hard and sad
that we have lost some of the connection
to elders or to the the people that are
knowing places and so we are thinking
about that a lot in trying to and a lot
of organizations how do we help mentor
how do we connect people to mentors that
might hold some of this so earlier yeah
you kind of spoke about like there was a
point of your life where you wanted to
quit and how tough and how hard it was
and I think that's something that can be
said about that because like the work
that you guys do is is not easy because
if it was easy everyone would do it so I
could kind of relate to that and kind of
my experiences with urban farming in
Chicago and it kind of how you know
there is a stigma behind farming but
like kind of I wanted to know like what
is all of your why like why do you do
what you do what wakes you up every day
to do the work that you do and continue
to do it even though is hard so yeah
yeah I won't lie to you well I think
about quitting every single year I've
had a lot of farmers do and I think part
of my why which is not that glamorous is
just stubbornness you know there was a
moment when my husband and I we we had
to hand dig our foundation because we
didn't have money for an excavator we
didn't really plan ahead and it's a
passive solar house so
it's gotta be facing solar south I
didn't pay attention in earth science
there's a thing called magnetic
declination the compass doesn't point
north it points like 12 degrees off or
13 degrees off so we dug our foundation
wrong and there was a moment we realized
that it was almost done like 85% done
took us four months with shovels and
Jonah's like we got digging this over
what he's like do you want to quit like
oh hell no do you want to quit oh hell
no like we're not quitters we're like
bleeding literally down our calloused
hands like four more months you know
we'll dig it and I think a lot of it is
that you know but probably more
glamorous reason it's like whenever I do
get really discouraged I'm like I always
joke with Jonah I'm just gonna go work
at the post office cuz I have that's
easy I don't know
but they'll be like some young person so
for example there was I was giving a
talk in Montreal yesterday and this
six-year-old child runs up into my arms
after and it's like I want to be a
farmer this beautiful black child with
these beautiful big puffy like hair bow
things and it's like I won't be a farmer
like you it's like I can't quit what
what gets me out of bed in the morning a
hot cup of tea got some but I I so enjoy
the stories and the ability to be
connecting with so many different people
that have this aspiration to be in
agriculture so that's what gets me up I
actually tell people that I don't like
to talk about my job too much because I
feel like I'm getting paid to do
something fun you know so I really I
enjoy that connection to people yeah
it's tough it was ten degrees this
morning but for me it's it's reclaiming
my my own agency around stuff you know I
get to pick what I'm gonna do today
right um sometimes the animals pick it
for me but um you know I get to choose
you know and it's not in a spirit of
exploitation and whatever labor I'm
putting in I'm able to help other people
reclaim that part of their own food
system their own stories right so even
if I'm providing you know some you know
the the variety of collars that they ate
that was really similar I cook a curry
or something people get to say oh I
remember
that was my family my mother he said my
mother's carry is way better than this
but it reminds me you know and it's just
making those connections because you
know I didn't see myself as part of a
food system you know I was just the
recipient of whatever my mother was able
to put together so so a lot more people
in communities to be being involved in
your own self agencies like really
important for me okay so um
Lea describes a common phenomenon that
men are students are familiar with and
seeing our peers of color at Cornell
saying them black and brown people can
confuse oppression on land but the land
itself and their ancestral traumas
associated with agriculture first in
European wises mindset important to
dismantle and secondly how have you seen
this mindset manifested um so men our
students are familiar with the saying
that black and brown people are can
confuse oppression online with the land
itself in like ancestral trauma so
European wises mindset important to
dismantle I think one important
distinction is it's really up to us to
dismantle that for ourselves is black
and brown people I wouldn't want anyone
who doesn't identify that way to walk
away and be like I really got a like
tell black people that they should be on
the land and they shouldn't be
traumatized it's like that's for it
that's our own healing that we get to do
and and what we found that works really
well for that is when we are in
community on the land so being just like
the one black farmer in a sea of white
on a woof program that's gonna be
reached Rama sizing but when it's 15 or
20 of us in a program together and we
can balance out the learning on the land
reflection with dance storytelling song
all of our ancestral ways of healing
that gives opportunity to imprint a new
memory of the earth that eventually
becomes stronger than that inherited
sort of epigenetic
a trauma memory of the earth but that's
that's kind of our work so like the work
of communities where our black and brown
is reparations it's the work of giving
back stolen land giving back stolen
resources making sure that all the
programs here accessible all of that
right and then our internal work I
really think is that undoing of trauma I
think it's so important not to start
from trauma to but not to ignore it you
know it shows up in trauma shows up most
often at the site of the crime and a lot
of times that's in land when you go you
know I can't I'm sure that the the
amount of people who come out from you
know we get students that come up from
New York City to visit the farm and the
first thing they do when they get off
the bus or they get off the car whatever
they look around and if they're
frightened and I'm like what's like hi
you know and this is like the first
thing everyone says is quiet and the
just silence is frightening right
because that could mean anything they
think something's out to get them it
could be a bear it can be a white man in
the woods like all kinds of like boogie
men that we have and it only shows up at
the site of the crime um and it's so
important to reclaim those spaces and
just say well you know that the trauma
is not present at the moment right that
predator isn't out to get you and if he
is he's got to get to me first you know
but it's really digging and finding our
own history I wanted to give a shout out
really quick to UM to doctor when I make
sure you get their name right dr. Austin
occur in right because a lot of times we
talk about George Washington Carver but
dr. Curtin was he study here Cornell
University is a soil scientist and he
was also dr. Carver's own partner in
research and the person who ultimately
bequeathed all his patents and research
to and he studied here right how many
people knew that that happened right why
isn't that a thing we need to talk about
the need to reclaim the history in our
own spaces and once we're able to do
that were able to participate right
because that was me and I'm there I am
or
so just get in no spaces so I think
those are all extremely important points
about that reclaiming the the connection
with the land and a in a positive way
but still recognizing the past and I
know that with some of the the work that
I've done around youth is also
connecting them with green spaces right
in their urban environments because the
more rural areas can be really
traumatizing for the first first time I
remember doing work and with inner-city
schools in Philadelphia and going to
rural forests even just you know and
outside of Philadelphia was a very scary
experience for some of the kids who had
never really been and like I've kind of
not even a really remote area and so
even urban farming and really thinking
about a lot of the natural areas in in
cities and connecting those and also
creating that new narrative you know
restoring these these places and
creating these kinds of positive
experiences and meeting particularly
youth where they are in that process so
this question is how can we as consumers
and you all as researchers be activists
for black and Latino X folk in
agriculture so um I think that one
community that is lives among us in New
York staying active in agriculture
that's been largely not I think
celebrated as assets and amazing
contributors to our food security are
our Latino Latin ex farmworkers and so
one really big project that we've
started it's really focusing on creating
pathways for them to move from field
work into management into ownership we
know that we can start with very small
gains of
being them build a confidence in the
ability to communicate and and be
leaders within their current employment
situation but the aspiration is that
they over time develop whole new
relationships and so I feel like in some
ways it's who do we have among us
already that have the skills and the
ability and the interest and then how do
we help them find their way I dislike
the the framework of consumer right
because I think that's something that we
have to undo too I see everybody who's a
recipient of the goods from the farm
whether it's education or food as a
co-producer this is someone who's
helping produce a different food system
and whatever it takes the strength in
the agency and able to do that whether
it's it's more funds in their pocket or
just more decision making processes for
them to participate in is is helpful
part of the question was about
researchers I think there's a the
importance for those of us who are on
faculty here at Cornell to be finding
and supporting and educating a new
generation of researchers a new
generation of scholars and many of the
young people who come here I guess I can
say young people many of them are in
their 30s or even 40s when they come to
do a graduate degree here at Cornell are
looking to be a different kind of
scholar and we need to hear that and we
need to recognize that and see that and
to help them to achieve that we've had
some wonderful examples in the past few
years one of whom was Bobby Smith who
came through our department who worked
with many people who's now at the
University of Illinois doing a postdoc
and in the process of being offered a
position to stay there as a permanent
faculty member so I think we need to be
the the point I want to emphasize here
is is the point about people young
people wanting to
different kind of scholars a different
kind of research to to do that work
differently we need to we need to see
that and hear that and we need to go
look for that and find it and support it
institutions like Cornell well I think
that wraps up the time that we have for
today and so I want to thank our
panelists for joining us and thank all
of you for being with us and Leah thank
you all so so much for making time and
sharing your stories and wisdom with all
of us and inspiring this conversation
and Marquand
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu